مهمة إنقاذ ناجحة رغم كل
الصعاب للأطفال الذين تم العثور عليهم أحياء بعد
قضاء 40 يومًا في أعماق
غابات الأمازون ، مما جعل الأقارب يبكون ،
دعهم يأتون إلى أجدادهم
إلى عمتهم وعمهم
جدتهم الرئيس الكولومبي غوستافو
بيترو لتبادل الأخبار السارة  مع
المراسلين ،
وجد السكان الأصليون والجيش معًا الأطفال بعد 40 يومًا كانوا
وحدهم بيان تاريخي للبقاء
اليوم ، هؤلاء هم أطفال السلام
وأطفال كولومبيا.
الكشافة لتحديد مكان
المفقودين منذ تحطم
الطائرة الصغيرة التي كانوا يستقلونها مع
والدتهم في الغابة في
الأول من مايو / أيار ،
وسرعان ما تم انتشال جثث والدتهم وشخصين بالغين آخرين ، لكن الأمل
لم يتلاشى أبدًا في العثور عليهم أحياء.
يجد الجيش الكولومبي آثار أقدام
وآثارًا متناثرة لإبقاء البحث
مستمرًا يومًا بعد يوم حتى
تظهر أخيرًا صورة من أعماق
الغابة ، ولديناهم وهم يعودون إلى
المنزل ،
إنه لأمر مدهش إذا فكرت في مدى
صغر سن هؤلاء الأطفال
لهم آه القس هو عيد ميلادها الأول
في غابة الغابة وهي تبلغ من
العمر سنة واحدة فقط